Why do humans get migraines?
The potential answer is a real headache.
Hey everyone, Matt Lieberman here for DNews.
Just about everyone knows someone who’s
had a migraine, or if you’re really unlucky,
you suffer from them on a chronic basis.
The Mayo Clinic defines a migraine as a “headache
[that] can cause intense throbbing or a pulsing
sensation in one area of the head and is commonly
accompanied by nausea, vomiting, and extreme
sensitivity to light and sound.”
They can last anywhere from minutes to several
days in length, and the pain and disorientation
can be so intense that it renders the sufferer
incapable of doing just about anything.
So why do we get them?
There isn’t one answer for sure, but a new
study authored by researchers at the University
of Toronto offers a compelling clue: participants
who witnessed physical abuse between their
parents were more likely to get migraines.
Men were 52% more likely and women were 64%
more likely to get migraines if they had witnessed
domestic violence as a child than those who
hadn’t.
This means, potentially, that migraines are,
at their core, caused by how the brain develops
long before we reach adulthood.
The headaches themselves are thought to be
brought on by abnormal brain activity and
an imbalance of serotonin in the brain.
Now serotonin is one of many neurotransmitters
found in the human brain, and it’s been
proven that when under intense levels of stress
and anxiety, the brain produces greater amounts
of fear-related chemicals, such as adrenaline,
and less of the chemicals associated with
relaxation and joy, like serotonin.
With this in mind, it’s possible to build
on the University of Toronto study and say
that witnessing domestic physical violence
raises the risk of migraines by adding viscerally
stressful memories to a still-developing mind.
If the pattern of abuse is constant, the brain
can very easily get used to overproducing
adrenaline and under producing serotonin.
So what can migraine sufferers do to avoid
migraines?
Avoid salty or overly processed foods, remain
well hydrated, and avoid caffeine, to start.
Try to reduce stimulation.
Bright lights and thumping bass are not your
friend.
Also, regular exercise can help release serotonin
into the body, reducing anxiety and making
migraines less likely.
Now we want to hear from you: Have you ever
suffered from a migraine?
How do you or your loved ones cope with them?
Let us know in the comments.